my
[Silence]
hope everybody is well
we ask allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala to
ease the various hardships that have
befallen
the community recently there's been a
lot of
illnesses associated with covet
of bonna there's been a spike in the
number of deaths unfortunately
associated with covet as well
so we ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to
hasten the relief of this calamity
that he protect all of us and heal those
of us who have been afflicted with this
i mean so
tonight we are continuing
in
this book of course is a tremendous work
and one of the most important pieces of
literature
ever written in the history of islamic
it's important for us to understand that
this book
is very pivotal because of the
very all-encompassing and holistic
approach
that ibn al-qaeda allah took
as he wrote this book
evidence
is a very very rare breed of scholars
what does that mean well
in order for a person to learn
any particular thing in in islam
in any meaningful way in a way to
be able to see things as they truly are
and approach
the level of scholarship
a person has to be proficient in a
number of sciences
islam itself is
learned and approached in a number of
it's it's categorized and divided into
various sciences that
the scholars use to teach the individual
avenues of islam
and any one of these sciences
in order to truly perfect
can take anywhere from five to fifteen
years
and
is one of the rare
types of scholars and when i say rare i
mean relatively rare there are thousands
him throughout history
but if we look at the millions and
millions of scholars
that is a very exceptional number
was proficient in the majority
if not all of the sciences of islam
and also the sub sciences so when we
speak about the sciences of islam
roughly the sciences of islam are
divided into
three sciences
number one the quran and everything that
is connected to it
number two the hadith and number three
the filk and understanding of the
jurispudence of islam these are the
general
categories right
and in these categories there are a
number of categories
also within
each one of these categories to work up
towards it
to build up in order to be able to
approach these
a person has to have other sub sciences
meaning a set of skills specifically
designed
to equip the person to understand these
foundational categories of islamic
study so we have for example
the science of exegesis right tafsir we
have the science of
hermeneutics which is we have the
science of grammar
we have the science all of these things
which in themselves
are tools to equip the person to be able
to
approach the quran and the sunnah
properly
is one of those very unique people
who has dedicated himself with an
exceptional mind
to be able to have studied and perfected
in large
the majority of these categories
the majority of these subjects
and so it makes him
uniquely qualified to write such a book
as
it's not just anyone who can write this
book
because it's not just the regurgitation
of information
but it's also a deep study
of how to harmonize this information put
it into order
and sequent it sequentialize it and so
forth
and so this book is an extremely unique
book and it's also an extremely
unique author who wrote who it
that it took to write such a book
allah
if we understand this we will understand
why
books such as are very very
scarce before and after abnor
and we will also understand
why this book has become such a
reference
for all of the scholars of islam to come
after
this is why we are giving so much
attention to this book
as the scholars of islam have given
attention before
tonight we are going to be discussing
[Silence]
which takes place between fajr and
this is called the doha which is early
morning
right this is pre-noon
or for noon
this is something that the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam would not
normally pray because usually his prayer
was at night
between asia and fajr however
he did encourage that a person pray at
least to raqqa
every duha and he as well
did on occasion praise allah himself
and we have discussed previously
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would praise
usually if he had not prayed the night
prayer
if he had not prayed to hedgehog
because of illness or exhaustion or
whatever it is that he would most
usually pray
in instead and we have mentioned the
narration of
regarding that
ibn begins this chapter with a narration
collected by
imam al-bukhari on the authority of
[Silence]
i have never observed the messenger of
even though i myself did customarily
make it
now this is a general ruling she did not
observe him
making salah but she is the same person
who said
previously that if he ever did not
pray salat al-qiyam
at night that he would pray
instead so what we take this to be
to under what we take this to mean is
that he would not pray swallow
for salat aloha he would either pray it
as because of some occasion or
because he had not prayed qiyam and
this is what the narration is take it
taken to mean
[Silence]
foreign
he mentions a narration here collected
by both bukhari and muslim
on the authority of
who says my
most dear friend
my most dearest referring to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
had asked of me
and encouraged me three things
fasting at least three days every month
praying to raka for luha
and that i pray swallet with her before
i
sleep at night
he mentions as well on the authority
collected by the imam muslim on the
authority of zaidebin
he said allah
[Silence]
this narration on the authority of
zaidebin
who narrates that the prophet salallahu
are those who are in often in constant
return and repentance
and turning to allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
he says the prayer of the awa being
is when the daytime
sun becomes very hot meaning just
when the sun is just
to reach its zenith the center of the
sky
because when the sun crosses the center
of the sky
and moves from rising to setting
just after that when it just crosses the
zenith when it becomes
after noon that is what
is just before it reaches the center
this is the time of this is the most
this is the most recommended
best time to make salat
according to the prophet salallahu
yet we see from his action that he would
not praise salah and rather he would
pray
the night time prayer in its stead
one
[Silence]
he says that masrook was one of the
students of
abdullah ibn masrud the companions
he says that we used to praise sj
and then we would remain there after ibn
masrud would lead us in salah and leave
we would remain there and then we would
pray swallow
meaning just before
and so he didn't know that we were doing
this
his students us meaning our his students
didn't know that we were doing this and
he said he
was informed of this
and he said to us he said to us is kind
of a rebuke
why are you burdening the servants of
allah with that which allah has not
burdened them with
if you must pray during this time
then do it in your homes what is he
speaking about
well in those times and still today for
those who are enthusiastic about
understanding islam
the people in the masjid they are
looking to
abdullah is the companion of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and they are looking to him as the
companion
and their spiritual leader
and as well the scholar and so
they are looking to what he does and
they're trying to emulate him
right also they're looking to his
students and watching what they do and
trying to emulate them
and so when the regular people see
the students of abdullah ibn masood
doing such very good
worship but nonetheless difficult
because of the timings of these worship
most people have to go to work
most people and they will try to strain
in order to emulate
the
students of abdullah and this would
become a burden upon them and so even
this essentially saying to them
what you're doing is correct but people
are watching you
and they're trying to emulate you and
you guys are out running them
this is a discouragement to them
and so if you must be so strict upon
yourself
do it in the privacy of your own homes
so as not to overburden people and cause
them
guilt for not keeping up with you
this is what even moses is essentially
saying
and this is something that is extremely
wise from abdullah
because if a person outruns
the common people who are trying to
follow him so far
they will give up in trying to follow
him
and they'll start trying to follow
someone else they'll become essentially
discouraged so a person has to
keep up imagine with me though this is
not in any way
belittling but it is a good analogy
imagine
when a person an adult is playing with a
child
let's say a young boy and this young boy
is trying to wrestle with his father or
his older brother
right well if the adult uses his
complete strength he could throw him
around a ragdoll he has
zero chance but a person doesn't do that
does he
a person plays with the child and
tries to show the child that he's
challenged
by the child why to build confidence
so that the child will not feel inferior
and feel a low amount of self-esteem
right and so
for this reason it is the same kind of
thing when you have people who are
scholars
people who are advanced people who are
well
disciplined and they outrun the common
folk
too much it will cause extreme dis
disappointment an extreme
it'll kind of take the wind out of
people's sails so this is what even miss
is speaking about here he says
is one of the taberine and he is one of
the most prominent students of abdullah
bin abbas
he was a fakie he was also murdered by
al-hajjaj bin yusuf
he says
he said i do not praise
even though i have an inclination to do
so
and the reason for this is that i do not
want to make it something obligatory
upon myself
what does that mean well when a person
starts and commits
to an act of worship let's say
fasting every monday and thursday or
fasting three days a week or fasting
or praying let's say
there's a commitment involved it's not
good for a person to do something
and then go back and then because this
will cause regression
the essence of how a person builds his
discipline is that once he
adopts a habit of worship he does not go
back from that that's it
he this is his bare minimum he has
raised the bar
or she and so said
recognized the level of commitment
involved
now a person may say what kind of
commitment is this you know to recap
there is a level of commitment because
this
is right smack dab in the middle of
a usual work day and so
it becomes strenuous for a person to
commit to it they may have time to do it
every now and then
but every single day no matter what
you're doing whether you're
whether you're driving or traveling or
coming or going or working or at home or
sleeping or whatever it is you know that
this commitment is something that you
have to abide by
and so we see the people of
understanding and the students of the
companions
that they would think twice before
committing to any act of worship now
this doesn't mean
that it's all or none if i can't commit
then i'm not going to do it this is not
what's intended
what is intended however is that a
person take his commitment seriously
now if a person makes will
and occasionally prays every now and
then without the
intention to always do it then that's
his intention but if you've made the
intention to
always do this and then you later break
that intention and regress
you have essentially taken a step back
and that is a kind of
small victory for a shaitaan this is how
it is looked at
he says
or he says and
there is now he is transitioning into
something called
is prostration of thankfulness
what is prostration of thankfulness
excuse me prostration of thankfulness
is that when something miraculous
happens or some kind of breakthrough or
some kind of
thing that a person receives
right that is of good news that they
fall in prostration out of gratitude to
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
this is the sunnah of the prophet alaihi
wasallam and his companions
so for example
in his famous story in buhari
when he repented and allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala sent down
some of the closing verses of surah
the ninth chapter accepting his
repentance
we see that
khabib in malik when he was given the
glad tidings that
allah had sent down verses of the quran
and the prophet sallallahu salallahu
he has just announced that your
repentance has officially
been accepted by allah and that
the boycotting that was previously
happening has thus
come to an end kabhi bin malik upon
hearing this news
fell in prostration to allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
out of thankfulness to allah and
likewise you know you are healed from
some illness
a person is you know saved from some
kind of
horrific accident let's say or a person
receives some kind of job
or some kind of good news that the
person has been awaiting
the person falls in sujud out of
thankfulness to allah
this is called the sujud of shukur the
sujud of gratitude or thankfulness
what does this mean well
unlike salah the correct opinion
is that sujud is not something
that has to be directed towards the
qibla
but it is better so a person can make
this sujud into any direction it doesn't
have to be faced towards the qibla
because it is not
it is not prayer likewise the person
merely falls in sujood
right and you don't have to say you
say in salah subhanallah
rather you would say anything that would
express gratitude
the point is the position not the
direction not necessarily what a person
is saying
likewise a person does not need wudu
to make sujud in the correct opinion of
the scholars
he says so the companions
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
they would customarily make this
whenever they received good news some
kind of
blessing or they were saved or spared
from some calamity
right let's say a person might be ill
and goes to take a test to see if
they're ill and then the results come
back that he or she is negative for this
illness this would be
the appropriate time according to the
sunnah to
make this sujud right
likewise a person you know
applies for some job or receives some
promotion or
their children succeed at something
anything that is
considered to be a blessing a particular
blessing from allah this marks the
proper
appropriate time to make
this
so
[Silence]
with the scholars of phil the jairus of
islam
commonly referred to as
the prostration of recitation
recitation of the quran so there are
a number of places versus
throughout the quran starting in surat
al-araf
the first one is found in the sequential
order of the quran
in which you know if you open the muslim
you'll find there's a line
over it but this is this is marked by
the sunnah that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would commonly make
sujud after reciting this
verse and so
the way that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam upon reciting this verse
would prostrate is as ibn al-qayyam says
here
rahimahullah that if he would come
across an ayah
that had a sajdah in it he would make
takbir
and make sujud
[Arabic recitation]
sujud
the correct opinion is that this sujud
does not have to be facing towards the
qibla
because it is not all of the scholars
agree
that it is better to face towards the
qibla
in this and any other sujud that a
person may make
likewise there is no explicit evidence
that a person
must make will do
have will do to make this sujud
but they all agree that it is better
to have when you make this sujud
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would say
in this one of the things that he would
say and there
we again refer people back to the books
of
to the books of dua
and atkar the fortress of the
muslim to reference these things
one of the adria or the atkar that he
would make
during this sujud is that which
translates to
my face has thus prostrated to the one
who has created it
given it its image and extracted
from it its hearing and its vision
with his ability and with his power
subhana with allah
even then says and it has not been
authentically reported
that the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam would make
takbir to rise up from this sujud
nor that he would make tashahud
after making this sujud nor that he
would make tesleem
after making this sujud this is
a reference from ibn al-qaeda
regarding the
different opinions of some of the very
famous scholars of islam throughout
history
with regards to the best way to make
sujuda tilawa
and so some of them such as in the
hambali medha it is
preferable that in order for a person to
make
surjuda tilawa
he should have will do
he should stand before the sujud
[Arabic recitation]
fall in prostration then rise up saying
we're not talking about prayer we're
talking about he's reading a verse from
memory or from the muslim that has a
sajdah in it
the first sajdah in the quran
sequentially
is the sajdah which is found in surat
al-araf
right in which allah mentions about the
angels
okay that went up upon reciting this
verse
the proper way is to face the qibla
having mudu
make tech beer fall in prostration
rise up make tashahud and make taslim
says none of this has been authentically
reported from the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
make prostration that's it
when he would rise up he would rise up
from the prostration without saying
anything
[Silence]
he says here says
that it has been authentically reported
that the various chapters of the quran
in which the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would make this sajdah
these chapters include surat sajdah
surat saad regarding the repentance of
[Silence]
likewise the last verse of surat in
najib
and likewise the third
to last verse of
surat al-inshikhak in the same
collected on the authority of
that the messenger of allah
taught him 15 places throughout the
quran
in which a sajdah should be made
he says three of these are in
the last fourth of the quran which
correctly starts with surat
or surat al hujurat
there are three places he mentions
says and there were two places in surat
al-hajj
towards the beginning and then towards
the end second to last verse of
[Silence]
m
now he goes into an issue of
he goes into an issue of hadith
discussing a narration that has been
collected
on the authority of even abbas
in which ibn abbas was narrated to have
said
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam didn't used to make any sajdah
in reciting the quran after hijrah from
mecca to medina
ibn al-qayyam says this narration is not
authentic
rather what's authentic is that
these 15 places in the quran and that's
the most
popular opinion and that's what the
majority of the muslim world has settled
upon
in most of the muslachev it is 15
places of sujud and this is what is most
commonly known
in the recitation of hafsan asam 15
places of sujud and in these 15 places
of sujud
there is no evidence that this was ever
abrogated
that this was ever changed that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam at
one point used to make these such debt
but then he stopped doing that
rather he made the sajdah
and he continued to make them until his
departure from this world
then he goes into an issue of discussing
various
discussing various narrators of
hadith and he goes into
an issue of the science of hadith and
the particulars of certain narrations
and certain narrators
which we will not translate
because honestly it's a little
consequence to
us in our issue here
this concludes our chapter for this
evening
we've discussed today
we've also discussed
it
and how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would customarily make these
sajd
we thank everyone for attending our
class this evening
i hope everyone is safe i hope to see
everyone soon
and hopefully i'm not sure how
socially we are going to recover bounce
back
from these new way of life that we're in
you know nobody touches anybody
everybody stays far we pray six feet
apart
i mean when this first started last year
this was so taboo it was almost
laughable
and now we start to see the seriousness
of it
and the implications of such an illness
that has
become a global issue and
hopefully allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala will
relieve this soon
and we can go back to the days of being
an armistance safe praying shoulder to
shoulder
foot to foot as the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam and the companions did
shaking hands with each other and so
forth i know that sounds kind of
people recoil at that thought now but
s
my
[Silence]
you